transgender athletes i don't [ __ ]
understand that you know
i understand if you know you want to
switch around i don't give a [ __ ]
but i'm a sports fan
that's a really new concept to me that
you can be a dude
right
ranked 80th in the [ __ ] world you
have your dick cut off you put on a
sports bra and now you're the number one
tennis player in the world just coming
out there with your man's shoulders
that doesn't seem fair i might be wrong
i might just be an old guy i have no
idea
but i'm hearing rumors like some of them
are getting into that mma you can't have
that [ __ ]
am i nuts that is a [ __ ] dude
beating the [ __ ] out of a woman
jesus christ he might as well hit her
with this discarded dick like a
flashlight
oh still no it's grounded her grounded
pound is incredible
right this this should be a career end
okay strapping everyone you ready
when people talk about the holocaust
when people talk about the holocaust
they talk about the tragedy and horror
of six million jewish lives being lost
to the nazi war machine but they never
mention the thousands of gypsies that
were killed by the nazis no one ever
wants to talk about that because no one
ever wants to talk about the positives
that's a very good joke for the
following three reasons firstly [ __ ]
funny well done me
secondly edgy edgy as all house a joke
about the worst thing that's ever
happened in human history and people say
never forget well this is how i remember
i keep bringing it up
third reason that's a good joke is
because there is an educational quality
like everyone in the room knows six
million jewish people lost their lives
to the nazis during world war ii but a
lot of people don't know because he's
not really taught in our schools that
the nazis also killed in their thousands
gypsies homosexuals disabled people and
jehovah's witnesses
no one knows what happened with the
jehovah's witnesses
you'd have to assume some jehovah's
witnesses came and knock in on the gates
of a death camp
with a copy of a magazine called
watchtower
some enterprising nazi guard oh yes come
in is very interested in your magazines
the watchtower we have the watchtowers
here
it is how you say kawinkidink
this is long journey for the witnesses
if you come in you freshen up take a
shower
all right i got some momentum let's
break out the abortion jokes so
if there was ever a time
my friend just had one her boyfriend
didn't contribute to the cost which i
thought was not cool you know
she's going through yeah that's not a
very noble stance i don't think
that is how low the bar is i'm like i
should pay a little bit for the abortion
of women like he's a hero he really is
no even the most pro-life person i
talked to was like wow chivalry is dead
that was the baby's name chivalry and
you know
dad
i'm just saying
that one that one's not for everybody
[ __ ]
i did that joke the other night and
somebody yelled out boo
i thought it was a baby's ghost but you
know
i'm just
put on a few pounds in the quarantine i
think we all put on pandemic weight the
grub hub the seamless i got to cut back
because i was a fat kid that was huge i
had man boobs growing up
isn't that weird about men when men gain
weight we grow female body parts right
like ladies you don't have to worry
about that like if a woman gains weight
just become a fat lady if a guy gains
weight we also become a fat lady
we don't grow male body parts not like
yeah i saw tammy by the river
she had a set of balls on her
there were some perks being a fat kid
i'd go to a sleepover my friend's like i
wonder what it's like to touch a boob
i'm like you're in luck
nobody likes man boobs i've asked around
i've done the research nobody likes a
hairy milkless tit
and yet man boobs are legal all over the
country
fat guy in cleveland take his shirt off
totally fine woman in cleveland takes
her shirt off in decent exposure but
those are the tits we like how do we
[ __ ] that up
we got weird boob rules in america
female tit exposed illegal male 2
exposed legal female to expose of the
baby sucking on it legal melted exposed
to the baby sucking on it very illegal
weird rules
this is how i look at it female tits are
like marijuana fun harmless yet still
mostly criminalized oh
man boobs are like cigarettes kind of
gross off-putting why the [ __ ] do you
bring those to the beach
we legalized the wrong one
you know what shocks me speaking of tits
my girlfriend's got huge knobs and uh
like like women have to walk into a
store and go i'm a b i'm a c i'm a d
guys aren't that strong if a guy had to
walk around going i'm an a he'd kill
himself
that wouldn't last 20 minutes right
some guy jump off a building suicide
note a minus every time every time
hey this is interesting the other day a
guy told me to suck a bag of dicks that
was interesting i never heard that
before
total stranger told me to suck a bag of
dicks
a whole bag of them
he was angry he didn't just you know
suck a bag of dicks like a greeting
oh suck a bag of dicks to youtube thank
you very much
yes
it's a lovely day for sucking several
bags of dicks
now what happened was i i cut them off
in traffic it was just one of those
things where i just i had to get in and
no one was in my car to judge me and i
just [ __ ] you know i just decided
he's not me so i don't care what happens
to him and i just cut him off i'm just a
shitty thing to do
and it was bad because he was coming
fast because he didn't imagine in a
million years someone could be that big
of an [ __ ]
and so when i did it he had to slam on
his brakes and his dog went poop in the
windshield it was really
very bad
very bad
and the worst part is when you cut
people off they don't vanish they're
behind you now so
looking back and he's like [ __ ] us be
so mad and he keeps trying to get next
to me because he just wants to see my
[ __ ] face he's just like i gotta see
this [ __ ] now i gotta see the
[ __ ] face of the piece of [ __ ] that
just did that to me and i keep cutting
him off because i don't want him to see
i'm ashamed of what i did
nope nope you don't
finally we get to a red light and i
gotta face them only because there's a
car in front of me otherwise i would
have [ __ ] blown right through there
but there he is just
furious and i'm not like i know it was
awful i shouldn't have done it
i'm not mad i was wrong why would i have
you men
and he's like [ __ ] you and then he
starts going like this because he wants
me to roll my window down like i'm
supposed to take part in my own abuse
during this argument you know
well i'm sorry i don't want to miss this
what do you have to say about me yes
how rude of me to shut out your anger
with my
so i did i rolled it down i'm interested
and he goes hey [ __ ] i'm like yeah
he says suck a bag of dicks
then he drove away
and i was kind of sad that he drove away
because i had a lot of questions
but that concept of sucking a bag of
dicks it's just weird like first of all
when you picture a bag of dicks
what do you see when you picture a bag
of dicks
is it like a plastic bag and they're all
mushing together like chicken parts and
with a
date written on it with sharpie keep it
in the freezer
or is it like a paper bag and they're
sticking out like baguettes kind of like
you went shopping
bringing home a bag of dicks for the
kids
there you go susie take a blue one you
know
you they were hanging in a window
somewhere give me two of those
and how do you suck a bag of dicks what
does he want me to do do you want me to
take a bag of dicks and suck it like
suck the side of the bag or
do does he want me to open the bag and
suck each dick individually and
throw the used ones in a bowl like
edamame shells like that
do i have to make them all [ __ ] you know
like how
you